مع تحول القتال في باخمت الى حرب استنزاف
للطرفين الروسي والاوكراني يحشد القاده
الاوروبيون اعدادا هائله من القذائف
والذخيره والصواريخ وبما انها حرب الزنزاف
اي تستنفذ الذخيره وكذلك ارواح الجنود
تكشف واشنطن نقلا عن مسؤولين امريكيين عن
حمله عسكريه لتجنيد مئات الاف المتعاقدين
اما في موسكو فالوعيد لغه يوميه سواء في
الكرملين ام على قناه التليجرام الخاصه
برئيس مجلس الامن الروسي الذي اكد ان
الاسلحه الغربيه والمدربين اهداف مشروعه
قال قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
ان قواته ستبدا قريبا هجوما مضادا في
باقمت بعد ان صامدت في وجه الحمله
العسكريه التي شنتها روسيا طوال الشتاء
واكد سيركي ان مقاتلي ميليشيا فاجنر
الروسيه يفقدون قدرا كبيرا من قوتهم وان
طاقتهم تنفد موضحا ان قواته ستستغل قريبا
هذه الفرصه كما فعلت من قبل قرب كييف
وخايفوا عندما سن الاوكرانيون هجمات مضاده
واستعادوا السيطره على مساحات واسعه العام
الماضي
في الاثناء افاد موقع ريبار العسكري
الروسي ان القوات الروسيه مستمره في تطويق
مدينه شمالا وجنوبا وانها تسيطر على مدينه
نوفو شمال وذكر المصدر ان المعارك مستمره
في محور للسيطره على منطقتي
شمال غربي المدينه واضاف موقع ريبارا ان
قوات فاجنر ما زالت تتقدم في المناطق
الجنوبيه بمدينه باخموت وان معارك عنيفه
تدور للسيطره على منطقه كراسونيه جنوب
غربي المدينه